[Music]
so time then for the press preview we're
going to take a first look at monday's
front pages and tonight we'll see what's
making the headlines with natalie faye
the editor of nottinghamshire live and
annabelle denham director of
communications at the institute of
economic affairs very good evening to
both of you we'll
speak in a moment after we've had a look
at the front pages starting with the ft
leading with the g7 summit and a move by
leaders there to stifle the russian war
effort in ukraine by imposing a price
cap on russian oil
meanwhile the metro reports on how those
leaders have been mocking vladimir putin
over photos of him showing off his
physique the headline there the full
monty
the eye says the g7 leaders are trying
to show some unity on international
matters in the face of their own
domestic political troubles at home and
the guardian reports how boris johnson
urged them not to give any ground to
russia on ukraine
while the mail has an investigation into
fraud and reveals that britain is now
the crime world's capital with three
billion pounds worth of cons being
committed a year
the sum leads with news that an
investigation is to be held into
millions of euros in cash allegedly
given to prince charles by katari sheikh
buckingham palace has already said that
the money was given to charity and that
all the correct procedures were followed
fightmare the star pictures a brawl that
broke out at a crowded airport after
passenger frustration with staff at
delays and cancellations boiled over
and don't forget by scanning the qr code
that you can see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
listen to us discussing them and to
discuss them i'm joined tonight by
natalie fay and annabelle denim great to
see you lots to talk about in monday's
papers why don't we start with the front
of the guardian natalie do not give
ground on ukraine the prime minister
tells leaders g7 leaders of course have
lots of pressures at home not only from
political opponents but also their
public um president putin though of
course has no such issues does it does
he you can do what he likes
uh well no not quite i mean that's
that's one of the top things on the
agenda at the g7 so obviously the g7
world leaders are gathered in bavaria uh
for a few days to discuss many items on
the agenda which we're probably going to
go through tonight because they're all
over the front pages and what the
guardian seems to be focusing on is the
sort of posturing that boris johnson's
doing trying to give over this
image of a strong leader
i won't bow down to what putin wants me
to do um if i'd been sort of bowing
under the pressure of back benches
putin would have been able to do
whatever he wanted so you know he's
doing a lot of talking lots of strong
words coming out from boris johnson
which were on the front page of the
guardian there
yeah i guess the the problem uh
annabelle is that it's been a very
united front so far hasn't it uh
in the war um uh that that ukraine and
russia are having but cracks are
beginning to show particularly with
france and germany who are uh
understandably concerned at the huge
cost of of helping to set to send arms
but also the the the cost of sanctions
absolutely you know when vladimir putin
embarked on this war i think it's safe
to say that one of his objectives was to
uh stoke division among the western
alliance and of course certainly at the
beginning of the conflict the absolute
opposite was happening we saw an
enormous uh
unification unity among um the west um
and they were very stingy minded when it
came to imposing sanctions a lot of
these nations went a lot further than
many people were anticipating including
introducing measures that represented
acts of economic self-harm uh in
ukraine's interest so certainly that was
the narrative earlier on in the
ukrainian conflict but i think now as
you say the cracks are beginning to
emerge i share of course natalie's
cynicism over boris johnson's rhetoric
over the last day or so trying to
position himself as a will work against
um backsliding by the us and other
western nations and this is of course a
position that has paid off uh back home
with the prime minister and he's got a
lot of domestic strife uh to deal with
when he returns to the uk after the g
sound at seven summit but you know
absolutely stakes really are getting
higher the longer that this conflict
goes on for both sides and i think the
challenge really is that you know since
the end of the second world war since
1945 we've become
used to the idea of decisive military
outcomes in europe one side wins the
other side loses but what we're seeing
in ukraine is a more protracted and
drawn out conflict that could last for
you know a year perhaps
many more um and that's something that
western leaders are going to have to
come to terms with um and i think we
could it can expect that they may not be
showing such a unified front uh in the
months and years to come
since the beginning of the war well of
course that's ukraine's biggest fear
isn't isn't it that uh that if we don't
keep up that pressure if we don't keep
spending a huge amount of money sending
arms and if we don't keep up pressure
with sanctions then the war will go on
for longer and we may even have a a
bigger european war
down the line the financial times
says g7 aims to hurt russian war chest
with price cap on crude exports and this
is one of the things they're going to
discuss isn't it in bavaria the
possibility of putting a cap on on
russian fuel
uh yes that's right i think that
question was aimed at me
so the financial times is leading on a
price cap on crude exports so the idea
being obviously russia
can't boost its war chest with the money
that it's getting from this um so this
is going on with the kind of a lot of
other sanctions that have been put in
place for example gold imports now being
banned and the sort of financial ones
that we saw right at the beginning of
the invasion as well so the eu's already
agreed to phase in a ban on seabourn
russian oil shipments
and the uk is um aiming to ban russian
oil imports by the end of the year so um
they're really trying to hit russia
where it hurts
um will it have an effect well
not sure the consequences could be quite
bad because obviously then we could be
cut off from the oil which is not
exactly what we want so it could
backfire and it's obviously a very
delicate balance there these leaders are
trying to strike
yeah front page of the i annabelle
leaders seek united front away from
turmoil at home how successful do you
think that this g7 summit's going to be
and how how successful will will the
nato meeting be in madrid
well i think i'd agree both with it with
a dose of uh skepticism i'm afraid you
know obviously that the eye newspaper is
focusing on uh the unity among
international leaders and the contrast
with how they are presenting themselves
on the world stage uh compared to the
enormous domestic pressures that they
are facing of course boris johnson has
tory rebels plotting his demise
potentially changing those rules around
folks and no confidence so they can have
one sooner than uh 12 months from now
macron has lost control of the french
national assembly just months after
being re-elected
as president and of course alarm bells
have been ruling ringing in the ruling
democratic party after biden's approval
rating fell below 50 percent last august
um you know his popularity is by by no
means guaranteed so i think that there's
you know a real contrast there between
how these leaders are
are looking and how they are presenting
themselves uh at the g7 stomach compared
to the strife that they they are facing
back home you know yeah as i say i you
know i don't expect that a huge amount
is going to be achieved at this g7
summit um certainly last year's didn't
lead to lasting change um so
as i say a bit of skepticism really over
what's going to be achieved
okay well natalie you touched on this
earlier it's on the front of the metro
we've been running the footage tonight
as well um when these g7 meetings happen
the cameras are allowed in for two or
three minutes right at the start of the
talks before the real business gets
underway then the cameras are rushed out
and they start their discussions but
sometimes i wonder if they forget that
the microphones are on as well because
there was quite a lot of dark humor
wasn't there um poking fun at president
putin
yeah it was really odd actually and um
like you say i think they're sort of
that maybe they forgot the microphones
weren't i'm not sure it was kind of that
awkward banter that you get when you
haven't seen uh you know work colleagues
from around the country for ages and try
and break the ice at the beginning of a
meeting or should we take our jackets
off should we take our clothes off and
and then boris johnson said well we need
to get our pecs out show that we're
stronger than putin because obviously as
you can see on the front of the metro
there they um they're referencing that
famous picture of putin when he was
riding topless on a horse so it was just
all very odd and um
maybe slightly inappropriate considering
what's going on
um you know it's very strange and when
you look at the pictures from the g7
there's some odd ones of boris grimacing
nobody's wearing a tie i know it was
really hot and
is urging vandalian wearing trainers
there i'm not sure it looks a bit like
it so
there's some odd stuff going on but yeah
maybe
the metro were describing uh president
uh vandalian as straight laced uh as
that uh as those jokes were being made
um let's move on to uh a different story
shall we annabelle it's on the front of
the sun it was an exclusive on the front
of the
sunday times earlier today this is the
rather bizarre story isn't it of prince
charles receiving
three million euros in a suitcase and in
fort my mason carrier bags i mean it's
the detail that's so strange isn't it
these allegedly um gifts to
charities uh that the prince supports
from a shake
yeah absolutely i think it's it's the
details and you know look at the
language in this article the the money
that's been bundled into a whole uh you
know and fortnum mason carrier bags even
if nothing on toward was occurring and
today's sunday times made clear you know
there was no suggestion that the
payments were illegal it it nonetheless
it you know it looks a little
strange that that was the method of
delivery and it's quite something that
you know this is being splashed on two
national papers two days running we've
now got um the probe the charity
watchdog is going to be investigating
the three million euros in cash that was
was uh handed to prince charles and you
know i think the wider concern here
really is is that the transition to
charles is king is going to be difficult
enough without stories like this uh
emerging um and now you've got this idea
that the cash is being
shoved into suitcases it's unsurprising
really that a probe is ensuing and that
you know this is a story that looks like
it's got legs yeah it goes back to 2011
uh between 2011 and 2015 at clarence
house uh saying that all proper
procedures were followed okay thank you
both for the moment uh coming up after
the break more from the papers including
this story it's on the front of the
daily mail britain is a three billion
pound ford capital uh is their story
we're discussing that uh and more in a
couple of minutes
[Music]
welcome back part two of the press
preview natalie and annabelle still here
natalie front page of the daily mail
this isn't a good story is it britain's
become the global capital of fraud
yeah this is really shocking it's a
special investigation by the daily mail
here i think um and it's talking about
well as you said britain's become the
global capital of fraud and losses um
losses amount to almost three billion
pounds a year so what they're talking
about here is the kind of fraud that's
suffered by well predominantly elderly
people vulnerable people people who try
and scam me out of money over the phone
on the internet
um you know i'm sure actually most
people watching tonight most of us have
suffered something like this you know
money comes out of your bank account or
comes off your credit card and you have
to try and scramble it back somehow if
you're not digitally literate or you
have access to the internet it's going
to be incredibly difficult you might not
even realize that the money's gone
missing so it says in this article that
most crimes aren't reported people don't
try and claim the money back i think
that's probably because it's so
difficult and the process is so
confusing so you know
bad news but i'm i'm not really
surprised to read that but but what can
we do about it well i think you know
banks need to step up and make the
process simpler basically and credit
card companies that's all there is to it
yeah and you're right it's it's not
surprising in many ways i mean even
today i've deleted at least three or
four scam emails i've had two scam texts
i've not had a phone call for a few days
but they're quite regular do you get
that as well annabelle
yeah you're absolutely right there's a
tsunami of scams that come your way and
it can be very difficult for your
average individual to
identify them and you know this article
points out that it's particularly the
vulnerable and the elderly who is being
uh preyed upon or um who are being
conned by these scammers um you know
it's an absolutely horrendous story
perhaps considering our financial
services firepower the city's position
globally it's not all together
surprising that the uk is being hit
particularly hard by this this wave of
scams but nonetheless the sums involved
are um
collectively absolutely uh enormous and
this comes you know just a couple of
days after which was warning of an
increase in scammers impersonating
energy firms to trick victims so you
know there's some detail there as well
um and not a lot to suggest that
anything's going to be done to address
it and i think part of the reason that a
lot of people don't uh report these
things is they simply shove their
shoulders and assume that the police are
simply too busy um to deal with it which
of course you know in many cases they
are so there's there's no
no obvious solution like like natalie
said beyond what natalie has said yeah i
mean well they will they will keep
trying um front of the ft uh natalie
this is a store a story about um uh
windfall tax on energy companies just
fill us in
yeah this is the controver about the
controversial windfall tax that uh rishi
soon that wants to introduce on energy
companies and how that might affect
investment in the future so um the story
is about rwe who is germany's biggest
utility um saying that they might
reconsider the 15 billion pounds they
want to invest in the uk
um if this when full tax goes ahead so
in a nutshell the uk is becoming a less
attractive place for energy providers to
invest in and you know that could stop
renewable energy projects going ahead in
the future
um it's all quite worrying really and um
i'm sure that's not what the chancellor
would want so he's stuck between a rock
and a hard place he really wants to you
know help people but at the same time
uh investment could not be forthcoming
because of this so a bit of a worrying
situation there
annabelle thought from you on this
sure well i think you know many
economists warned before it was
announced there would be a windfall tax
on oil and gas companies that win full
taxes are across the board uh a bad idea
i mean for a start companies don't pay
taxes people do so windfalls reduce the
dividends paid out to company
shareholders and these companies aren't
owned by fat cats but by all of us or
many of us through pension funds and
insurance uh
insurance firms and they hurt consumers
by stifling competition but the other
argument against them is that they risk
a decline in investment few investors
are going to put funds towards um an
industry that is subject to an unstable
tax policy
i mean
bp
weren't fully opposed to it were they
well i suspect that bp were were
triangulating and in fact there were
announcements in the days after sunak
made that announcement that there would
be some kind of decline in uh investment
you know as i say there are a few
investors who are going to want to put
money towards uh industries that are
operating under unstable uh tax policies
um and of course you know the other side
to this is that the idea that the
government has the wisdom and the
insight to determine which businesses
are making excessive profits and to tax
them differently and if these firms are
getting a win for one year but but are
um
not making a profit in subsequent years
or running at a loss does that mean the
government will offer them a rebate so i
think it's a very uh bad policy a messy
policy and not a road that the
government should be
going down at all okay all right let's
end on as the guardian puts it a little
bit of disco joy diana ross has been
wowing the crowds at glastonbury natalie
yeah excuse me doesn't she look
absolutely fabulous there um
the outfit the sequins the feathers the
headdress absolutely everything so she
was um playing in the tee time legends
slot which um everyone absolutely seems
to love i've never been to customary but
i have watched some of the performances
and people are getting quite emotional
about it you know it's been three years
since glastonbury's been on i watched
some interviews with people talking
about diana ross's performance the woman
was crying because she loved it so much
so she really connected with the crowd
and
i think she came out with a line of
something along the lines of i love the
idea of singing in the daytime because i
can look into all of your eyes and you
can just imagine everyone wow i know she
was great she was great at the jubilee
concert as well wasn't she just
fantastic thank you both very much
indeed